[Music]
hello troops Angela Bishop from Network
10 Australia first of all
congratulations everyone incredible
effort such a clean sweep for the series
so well deserved I am going to start by
singling out my dear friend Nicole
Kidman if you don't mind congratulations
on Best Actress as well on such a
pivotal night as tonight at this special
time in Hollywood this is the success of
such a female centric story as this make
this win a little more special a little
more significant somehow yeah absolutely
it's it's it feels like we're Shay and I
were just talking about it that for this
show to be resonating right now at this
time is extraordinary we're incredibly
grateful but it also allows us to speak
and be heard miss Reece was saying to be
heard and to be seen and to stand up for
what this show is about and the issues
that we show is dealt with back this is
for Reese but this one actually hi
congratulations
two things I would love for you to talk
about the decision to transition to
Andrea Arnold and her sort of singular
vision for season two and to leave Sean
mark and also Oprah did a really cute
impression of you I wonder if you have
one of her well first to say we are so
deeply grateful to John Mark valet his
vision for these characters the way he
guided us everything he put his artistry
and his sort heart and soul into it and
his musical taste is all over this
miniseries unfortunately he was busy we
did try and accommodate but we wanted to
get the
the show the second season started soon
because I do think the public wants it
soon and so we were very lucky to have
Andrea Arnold respond to the material
and David wrote incredible scripts Leon
wrote an incredible piece that he's
adapting and and so we're just thrilled
to welcome her to our family and Jean
mark has welcomed her to the family and
we're just thrilled we all get to do
this again with each other so yes and do
I have an Oprah impression you get a
Golden Globe and you'll get a Golden
Globe and you get a Golden Globe hello
for Italia you know Italian television
over here for is and call your first of
all congratulations to all of you for
the Globes
but to raise any call you're both
wearing black can you give a message do
you have a message for the woman as well
tonight okay we all decided you know
it's been a really and it's been a
difficult year for our industry
discovering a lot of things a lot of
things have come out of the darkness and
into the light and I think there was a
collective feeling that it wouldn't be
business as usual because I think we can
have to be forever changed in this
moment we are more United as an industry
than we have ever been men and women
determined to change our own industry
but also shine a light on other
industries because we get a lot of
attention we're very privileged to be
here we get to tell stories and there
are a lot of people in other industries
who don't get this opportunity to speak
up so hopefully this is a small gesture
that will continue to resonate
and well I've been working for two
decades for un women trying to eradicate
violence against women it is so hard to
be heard in amongst all the noise and so
I think right now we have the chance to
be heard and that's why we're doing it
we're all doing it because we're asking
to try and elicit change and that
everyone will help and participate so
that we can do that Julia pepper from
Xinhua News Agency of China
I'm curious there's so many strides
being taken now with time out with the
legal fund that will be helping for
women how can we actually get more yeah
and you're all producers how can we get
more production spending into female
centric projects and female directed
projects I may be wrong with this but I
think the three top grossing movies are
some of the highest grossing movies had
women were women centric with women
leads so that's it's not just in
television and it's about as women
saying I'm going we're going to have
female directors I'm in the midst of
working with not just a female director
but a female DP they are so rare I've
made over 60 films I've worked with one
other female DP so this is the second
one ever which is not right you know and
a female first ID so we're just trying
to change the statistics and we need the
help right here in the middle ish for
recent Nicole you guys really pioneered
the show and worked really hard you
talked about your fyc this year to get
it going and I'm kind of curious about
your bond
working together and off-camera if you
can kind of talk about that in your
special friendship that you formed well
we have special friendships with
everyone in this group it's been an
extraordinary experience I think so much
of my career for 27 years I never got to
work with another woman and to be able
to have incredible scenes and the
opportunity to
have a spectrum of female behavior that
women look different they have different
socioeconomic backgrounds they have
different experiences in life I think to
start to talk about seeing a more
dynamic woman on film I think this is
just the beginning and we hope to
continue that and even make it more
diverse and make it more inclusive make
it more look like the world really looks
and it's really important and when when
women are the architects of the story
the stories change and you see things
differently so we need to see here
stories from different types of people
different every type of person and I
think that's been going on too long the
same people telling stories over and
over again and it feels like it's
changing it really does
you